get out everything your husband and I
had been doing researching and dreaming
and building you ought to keep going
without him how much do you know about
what Wells was working on when he died I
wanna burn Laurent find out where she's
bad you have to assume Wells told her
about this project you know where she's
been who she's talked to with no idea
what she's told people about whatever it
is you're doing it's so strange about
this I don't quite understand what all
the physics tell us that time travel is
impossible why do you think Wells was so
secretive about his work maybe that
woman's impersonating you stealing your
identity it wasn't someone impersonating
me that wasn't me you need a doctor
someone who can explain what's happening
to you I don't think a doctor can
explain what's happening to me
there is a time machine no I
I'm gonna find her I'm gonna figure out
why I send myself back
tell me what this is there's a camera
head in the house but that's not all she
is paranoid delusion I think she wants
to pull something off wanna show him how
it's done
just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should this is getting
out of control
if you could go anywhere anytime
anywhere
you